chris how you doing bud
hey guys
yep what do you got for us tonight can't
hear that great on this side but i can
get a bit of it um
so a rich longtime fan um a fellow
author and i'm actually writing about my
experience on this stuff i'm about 65
000 words in
need the last two chapters work
themselves out but it's coming
and i'm i'm really glad you brought down
on guys need to learn this stuff and and
in terms of a question i guess i'd like
to offer some experience or some some
advice from going through this
experience and don i'd love your
feedback on it
do not fight this fight alone there are
other men that have gone through it
before you
the psychological and emotional toll
that's gonna take on you is gonna it's
it's designed to crush you so find other
men who have been through it don't go
through this alone
it's it's a it's a
marathon that's got to be run at a
sprint's pace you have to think the long
game you have to win the long game
and you have to stay in the fight the
machine is designed to take you out of
the fight it's designed to bankrupt you
and make it so you can't fight so so
play long game
um
and and stay cool don you mentioned
something about you know stay cool stay
calm don't overreact
especially when you're you know in front
of the judge et cetera et cetera
um and always know that the kids are
always watching
as as all the society
everything you do is going to leave an
impression on them for the rest of their
lives and and guys just don't fight it
alone yeah chris that's that's really
great everything you said i i agree with
and i really appreciate your pointing
out the kids are always watching um
don't bad mouth mom because it you know
no even if she richly deserves it don't
bad bath mom right um that that's not in
front of the kids you know you can do it
to your buddies when you're not having a
beer but not in front of the kids
and expect it's coming to you and expect
they're hearing it about you all the
time i mean every court filing is going
to paint you as the devil incarnate you
are the worst thing that ever walked the
face of the planet you are going to be
torched you just burned at the stake
just you know let it duck water off a
duck's back you got to get past it and
chris i've seen people be broken by this
and i think it's really important to
you know connect with other men who have
been through this
um the other thing that i that i
intended to mention earlier when i talk
about keeping calm is this i've seen
fathers who believe that they can
arm wrestle the judge into doing what
they want the judge to do that they can
they can win it through you know legal
argumentation
judges and family law courts have a
great deal of discretion and what you
have to do is to win their heart first
you make them want to decide the case in
your favor you can't make them
reluctantly come to your
position
they will find ways to avoid it i'm a
law school graduate i knew this was
coming when i went to law school i
specialized in family law i still wasn't
prepared for
my attorney's call it's liar's court
and and truth does not that literally
does not matter it's all perception and
you have to manage the perception right
yeah good point thanks for sharing that
chris yeah rich thanks for all you do
don good luck with everything yeah
christopher um if you're if you're still
there listening christopher when do you
uh get your book yeah absolutely great
when you get your uh your book published
uh shoot me an email i'm usually fine
too is the title of that book
great i'm sorry hashtag he2 is going to
be the title of it okay okay good times
you